So today we have a lot of stuff to get through,
but it's all going to be fairly formal and we're not,
we're not,
we're not gonna have time to play a game today.
So there's going to be a day we have to learn some new ideas.
So the reason we need to go through some new formal ideas today is we've kind of
exhausted what we can do with the ideas we've gathered so far.
So just to bring us up to date where we are in the first half of the semester.
So before the midterm we looked at simultaneous move games and what,
where do you want this simultaneous move games were games where when I take my w
we're not,
when I make my choice,
I don't know what you've done.
And when you make your choice you don't know what I've done.
All right?
And since the mid term we've been looking at a simple examples of sequential
move games,
sequential move games under perfect information in which I typically do know
what you did when,
when I get to make my choice.
All right.
And you know,
I'm going to know what you did when I get to make my choice.
And what I want to be able to do moving forward is I want to be able to look at
strategic situations that combine those two settings.
I want to go to analyze games which involve both sequential moves and
simultaneous move games.
All right?
Oh,
and in particular I want to see how we can extend the technique we've been
focusing on for the last few weeks,
which is backward induction.
I want us to see how we can extend the notion of backward induction to cope with
games with some parts of sequential and some parts are simultaneous.
Alright,
so we can look at a lot of examples and we're going to introduce some new ideas.
And I know you're trying to walk you through that today.
So that's our goal.
Let's start with an example.
So here's a very simple game in which player one moves first and has three
choices.
Let's call them upper,
middle and down,
and then play a two moves.
And player two has two choices
from each of these nodes and we'll call the choices suggestively up and down,
up and down,
and he will just call them left and right.
All right,
in the payoffs are as follows,
four zero 0404401200 so this is just a standard game of perfect information,
much like all the games we've seen since the mid term effect.
It's a relatively easy one.
So we know how to solve this game.
We sold this game using what?
Using backward induction.
And that isn't so hard here.
We know that play a to uh,
if pay or two finds herself up here,
she will choose for rather than zero.
If she finds herself here,
she'll choose for other than zero.
And if he finds herself here,
she'll choose two rather than one.
So player a one won't want to go up here because he'll get zero and he won't
want to go into the middle because he'll get zero and he won't want to get.
And if it goes down a play,
one more shoes left and,
and play play one.
We'll get one play,
one more shoes down.
So backward induction predicts that player one chooses down and play at two
responds by choosing left and just staring at this a second notice that the
reason in this game,
it's taking a step back from back conduction a second.
The reason play a one did not want to choose either AARP or middle was because
that move was going to be observed by player too.
And in either case play it too was going to crush by a one,
right?
So if player one went up,
play a two was playing this sort of stripping competitive game with player play
a wine and play it play a two could design it could make a choice that God gave
to four and one zero.
And conversely,
if player,
uh,
one shows middle player two could crush plant player one by choosing Aarp,
which gave once again play a two four and player one zero.
So there was good reason here to avoid going into the part of the game following
up or middle.
And the reason was two weeks.
Two has a huge second mover advantage in those parts of the game that clear to
everybody.
So I now want to consider a similar but importantly different game.
So I'm going to draw the came again before joined him.
He said we're going to do,
so I want to,
I I want to introduce a new idea and the new idea is going to be that player to
player two will not be able to distinguish between AARP or metal just to say it
again.
If player one chooses down play it too will observe that just as we've done
before and they'll put under in our standard perfect information games.
But if player one chooses either up or middle,
I want to capture the idea,
the player to doesn't know which of those two choices was made,
right?
That's clearly going to change the game a lot.
And the first question is how do we represent that idea in a tree?
So let me try and show a good way to represent that in a tree.
The game has the same structure to it.
Play a one is again,
choosing between our Midland or down and play a two.
Once again,
it's choosing here,
up or down,
up or down and here,
left or rights.
And the payoffs haven't changed.
They're still four zero 0440041200.
So that's exactly the same as you have in your notes already.
But now I want to to,
to adapt this tree to show how he indicates that plant to cannot distinguish,
cannot observe whether one shows up or middle but can observe if player one has
chosen down.
And the way we do that,
very simply,
we draw a dotted line
between the two nodes of player to between which two cannot distinguish.
So this idea here,
what this dotted line indicates is that these two nodes are say in the same
information sets.
So a new idea here is the idea of an information set.
Uh,
I did.
I did,
Thank you.
Observe a four four zero.
All right.
Pay For pay.
I was meant to be the same on the left is on the rise.
All right,
so the idea here is that too
play a two
cannot distinguish
these two notes.
Plants,
who knows that she's in this information sites.
She knows that player one must've chosen either up or metal.
She knows the play.
One did not choose down but she doesn't know whether she's really here
or here.
Okay.
Now what happens in this game?
This game is a very different game.
Why is it a different game?
What does trying to apply that loosen format,
that loosened tuition we applied,
we talked about before,
we said previously in the old game that if player one shows up to knew that
player wanted shows mop and observed that by choosing down play or two could
crush one and if player one chose middle player too could observe that player
wanted chose metal and this time by choosing op could crush one.
The problem is that now in this new game play a two doesn't know whether he's
here,
whether she's here.
In which case you would want to choose down or here in which case you'd want to
choose out.
Yeah.
Right.
So play as twos.
Choice is not so obvious anymore.
That's simple.
Backward induction arguments has disappeared.
Moreover,
player one knows that player two will not be able to reserve between upper
middle.
So it isn't necessarily the case that player one will want to choose down
anymore.
It's still true that if plan one did shoes down that play a two would be able to
observe that and we'll choose laughs.
So that part of the arguments are the same.
Okay.
What do you think's going to happen here?
Well,
we don't know,
but let me give a suggestion.
What might happen here.
Play a one might say,
hey,
I could randomize between upper and middle.
I could choose half the time up and half the time.
Middle if I choose half the time up and half the time.
Middle play a two isn't going to know in general isn't gonna isn't gonna know.
What I've done isn't quite clear what players two's going to do and since I'm
randomizing between upper middle,
whatever player two is going to do,
I'm going to get half the time,
four and half the time.
Zero for an expected value of two.
Right.
Just say it again.
So play a one might decide in this game to randomize 50,
50 between upper middle,
knowing that half the time,
therefore he will get to over four and half the time he'll get for an expected
value of two,
which notice is better,
is better than he got my choosing down.
Alright,
so this change in this game,
changing the inflammation in this game,
not only the to a different game,
it led to a very different outcome.
All right,
so here,
here,
one might for example,
might randomize
between up and middle.
And over here we know exactly what one does.
One
chooses dialogue,
run,
chooses down.
If we get very different outcomes because of this change information in the
gate.
And the theme of today is that inflammation is going to matter.
The way we're going to model information is by thinking about these information
sets.
And as we go through today,
I want to start giving you some formal definitions.
So this is the idea.
Now let's look at the formal definition.
Is he a lot of writing today?
So I hope,
hope.
Uh,
I hope you brought a notepad with some room on it.
Alright,
so the first formal definition of the day comes off that last example.
The full definition is the idea that I want to capture.
I want to capture the idea that players down the tree may not know exactly what
was done up the tree and the formal definition is gonna is gonna go through the
idea of an information session.
So an information set
off player.
I in this case,
both planning to but more generally of player.
All right.
Is a collection or a set if you like,
it's a collection of player eyes.
No,
between went or I guess it could be more than two.
So let's say a manwich
among which I
cannot distinguish.
All
right.
It's the turnout that by clever use of information stats,
we're going to be able to use our technology.
Yeah.
Technology of drawing trees to capture all sorts of interesting and increasingly
complicated information settings.
All right.
In this particular game,
it's the case the player one knew that player to was not going to be able to
distinguish within upon metal in this tree and player one knew the player too
would be able to distinguish and the lefthand tree we can even use information
sets in a more laboratory to capture the idea that player one may not know what
patty was going to know and I won't do that now.
I'll lead that later and you'll see some examples of that on the homework,
right?
So we have our formal definition.
This is going to be all the first of our big tools of the day.
But let me just put down a few things that we have to be careful about.
A couple of rules.
So these information sets have to obey certain rules
and certain things are not allowed,
certain things are not allowed.
So in particular the following is not allowed.
Here's a tree in which plan one moves first and play at too does not observe
player ones move.
So these two nodes are player two's nodes.
Between where they are.
The same information stats,
which means player two is not meant to be able to distinguish between these two
nodes and suppose new over the tree looked like this.
Yeah.
Okay,
so I claim that this is,
this is crazy.
We couldn't allow this.
It wouldn't make any sense to allow this.
Can you want to see why?
Why wouldn't it?
Why?
Why is this not really a sensible tree?
You want to see that?
Okay.
Why is that not a sensible tree?
Here's the,
yeah,
don't want to grab somebody.
Yeah,
it was just the guy behind his.
Yep.
That's okay.
That's great.
Shout out a player to knows that he has three choices.
Then he'll know he's at the top.
Knowed exactly.
Exactly.
In this tree you haven't,
but the payoff sin.
But if player to play at Psu observes that she has three choices,
she knows she must be at the top node.
If she observes she has two choices,
she must be at the bottom node.
All right,
so in this,
in this tree,
it was supposed to be the case that two didn't know whether she was here or
here,
but merely by observing how many choices she has,
she could infer whether she was at the top note on the bottom node.
So that can't make any sense.
So this is not allowed.
So we'll put a great cross through that one.
Now the second thing that's not allowed is a little bit more subtle and actually
it's an interesting thing mean this is just kind of bookkeeping.
But the second thing is more interesting.
So let's have a look at it.
Here's a more interesting tree.
You play a one loose first player to observes that move Orion player to move
second
and then at the bottom of this
play a woman may have another shelter to move again.
So again,
I haven't been payoffs in here.
Yeah,
wait,
one moves first,
play a tooth loose second and if play out two shoes is down here or up there,
then player one gets to move again.
Now I claim again that this is not a sensible tree.
It's not a sensible arrangement of information.
Sense.
Can anyone see why this isn't a sensible,
why has this not sensible?
Yeah,
Stephen.
Yeah.
Shout it out.
Player one knows what node he's at based on the first choice anyway.
Exactly.
So to get to the upper node here,
for player one player,
one must have chosen up before and to get to the lower note here,
player one must've played down before.
So provided the player one remembers his or her own move.
She knows where she is that I have to provide the player.
One can recall what she herself did earlier on the tree.
She should be able to distinguish these things.
So we're going to rule this out,
but I just want to make a remark here.
There's an assumption in rolling it out and the assumption is we're assuming,
perfect recall or perfect memory.
Okay.
We're assuming perfect recall.
And people don't always in the real world,
uh,
players don't always have perfect recall.
There are two reasons and we we're always going to assume this.
Let me just make a remark.
There are two reasons why people might not have perfect recall.
One reason is like me,
they're getting old,
right?
They simply can't remember what they did yesterday.
All right?
So when I'm driving home,
I know roughly how many traffic lights I have to go through before I turn
rights.
Uh,
but I sometimes forget which traffic late I'm at and I turned right too early or
too late.
All right,
that doesn't happen to you guys.
What happens to me as I'm getting a bit?
So,
you know,
all right,
so old age would rule out perfect recall and more important example perhaps is
if players of games are themselves institutions,
it's sometimes useful.
And we'd often talked about it in this class to a mansion,
a player of a game being a firm or a country or some kind of institution in
which the actual decisions maybe being taken by different plans,
different actual people within the firm,
institutional country.
Right?
And this assumption of perfect recall is saying that the players within the
institution knew what the other players within that same institution we're
doing,
right?
So if we,
if we're modeling a General Motors,
there's one player.
This assumption is assuming that the chief financial officer and the chief
executive officer of GM or observing each other's actions are on the same page.
The left hand knows what the right hand's doing.
All right.
We are typically going to assume that,
but just to make the point,
it isn't assumption.
All right,
and it's quite interesting.
Just see what happens if you were an accent.
All right,
so with that in mind,
we can move to our next definition,
and this is something I've referred to early on in the class,
but I want to be format.
I know he can be formal.
We've talked to her on this class about the idea of perfect
information.
So for example,
when we talked about zoom mellows Theorem,
we talked about games have perfect information and we sit in formally what this
was a game of perfect information is a game where each player in the game can
observe all previous moves.
All right?
That's it.
That was our informal definition,
but we can now give a formal definition.
Very simply perfect information as to is is a setting where all information sets
or information sets
in the tree
games have perfect information games where all inflammation sets in.
The
Trey
contain just one note.
All right?
It will be a clear head.
So what we're saying here is here,
if we have a tree in which every information said is a single tenant,
we basically never bother with any dotted lines.
That's a game of perfect information.
And that shouldn't be a surprise to anybody here cause that's exactly how we
drew trees since the mid south.
Is that right?
Of course the novelty is we're now going to be allowed to look at games of
imperfect information,
right?
The reason we're doing this is because it will be interesting as an example,
we just see you to think about games where information is not perfect.
So what is the definition of imperfect information?
Imperfect information.
Formal definition is not perfect.
Inflammation,
all right?
We define what perfect information is.
Imperfect information is the rest high.
In the real world.
There's a lot of games,
the turnout to have imperfect information.
There's lots of strategic situations where I'm going to be able to observe some
of the things that you've done,
but other things,
I won't know quite what you've done.
Okay.
Let's go straight to an example.
All right,
so I,
I don't think we really need to keep that definition very focal so it's get rid
of that mod.
Okay.
All right.
Let's do an example in many examples today.
All right,
so this example is going to be a tree
in which player one of the moves first.
Okay.
Plant to cannot observe this move and sometimes rather than leaving both of
these nodes with a two,
I'll just put a two on the information set,
right?
So just to indicate that both of these nodes along to play or to supply or to
move seconds and we'll call player ones,
move up or down and we'll call play a tos move left or right,
kind of suggestively
left or right.
Okay.
So what's the information said here?
The information set is indicating the fact that player to cannot observe whether
player one moved up or down player to cannot observe whether player one shows up
or down.
I know what does that mask,
I hadn't with the payoffs in yet,
but I want a second it masters because had this game in the game of perfect
information had this information set.
Had there been two information sets here,
this dotted line not been there.
Then player two could have chosen separately whether to choose left or right at
this node or left or right and left or right at this mode,
but since player to doesn't know whether she's at the upper node or the lower
nodes,
he doesn't know where the player one she's up or down.
She really only has one choice to make here.
She's,
Oh the choosing it left at both nodes or she's choosing right at notes and just
to pull it back to our first example in the class
we saw this same feature.
Then when we moved from a game of perfect information to a game of imperfect
information,
we reduced the choices available for player to hear play two could choose
separately up or down at these two different nodes,
but here play a two only makes one choice.
That has to apply to both nodes because player too can not distinguish those two
notes.
All right,
so let's have a look and see once we put some payoffs on it,
what it does in this particular game.
All right,
so here's some payoffs.
Two to minus one three three minus one n zero zero
all right.
Once again,
play a two cannot separately choose at the upper node or the lower node.
She's either choosing left or she's choosing,
right,
but it turns out that this game is a little easier than the game we started
with.
Why is it easier than the game we started with?
It's easy.
The game that we started with because from player to his point of view,
whether she thinks she's up here or whether she thinks she's down here,
she has the same best choice.
Any of the case.
If she thinks she's at the upper node,
then by choosing left she'll get to and right,
she'll get three.
So rates seems better if she thinks she's at the lower node,
then choosing left gets minus one and right get zero.
So once again,
right is better.
So in fact,
in this particular game,
regardless of whether a player to thinks that play or one shows up and hence
she's at the upper node or the thick player to thinks the player one shows down
and hence is at the lower node play a two is going to make the same choice in
this game,
namely,
right?
So notice that this particular game actually souls out rather like backward
induction rather light back from March.
We actually know even though even though play a tos choice is a little bit more
complicated that she doesn't know where she is,
it's actually clear what player were to,
we'll do a at this inflammation status.
Now we pushed this forward a little bit harder.
We can see why play a one in this game has two strategies are up or down and
play of two has two strategies.
She either shoes his left or right and there's just only has two strategies
cause he has to choose the same thing at these two nodes.
It doesn't know where she is.
All right?
Okay,
so let's turn up the Matrix for this game and see if it looks familiar.
All right.
It's a play.
A one is choosing between up or down and play.
It too is choosing between left or rights and the payoffs are as follows.
Up left is two two uprights is minus one three down left is three minus one and
downright is zero zero
right?
Is there as the rest of,
what game is this?
It wasn't meant to be a trick question.
So somebody uh,
somebody wave at I'm an hour.
What game is this?
Shout it out here.
Like this,
this prisoner's dilemma,
right?
This is a,
this is an old friend of ours is this prisoner's dilemma.
Again,
we were sort of very first day,
but notice what are we seeing here?
This is prisoner's dilemma that we have seen many,
many times.
That's almost a unbearably familiar to most of you,
right?
In the hinge prisoner's dilemma as represented the way in which we've talked
about games before the midterm,
but here is the same game.
This is also prisoner's dilemma,
but now I've drawn in a tree here I do it in a matrix and here I drove in a
tree.
Now that we have information sets,
we can represent all the games that we studied before the mid term.
All the games that were simultaneous move games.
We can study using trees by building inflammation says,
I watch the key observation here.
It doesn't really matter whether player one moves first or pay or two moves
fast.
It doesn't really matter what's happening temporarily in this game.
What matters is inflammation.
When player one makes her move,
she doesn't know what player is going to do,
alright,
and Po,
it doesn't do it to,
is doing.
And when player too,
he makes her move.
She doesn't know what one is doing right?
And that's a simultaneous moved game.
Even if time is passing,
the key is information,
not uh,
not time.
All right?
Now on the way here,
I snuck something in and I should just tell you what I smack him.
I snuck in what a strategy is.
I went from a tree or an extensive form game,
two or normal form game,
and we've already done that a couple of times before in the class.
We did it with the entry game for example,
uh,
about a week ago.
All right?
But they're,
all we did was we defined what a strategy was in a game of perfect information.
And just to remind you a strategy and a game of perfect information is a
complete plan of action.
It tells the player and question what they should do at each of the nodes high.
But now we have to be more careful.
We can't have a strategy.
It works.
Once we moved to imperfect information,
we can't have a strategy tells you what to do at each of your nodes because you
yourself can't distinguish between those nodes.
All right?
It's,
we need to adapt our motion,
our definition of a strategy to make it appropriate for these more complicated
games.
So let's just adapted in the obvious way.
Definition
definition.
I'll just define pure strategy has been help.
A pure strategy,
a pure strategy,
all plan.
I
is
a complete plan of action.
So this is the same as before.
It's a complete plan of action.
What does it mean to be a complete plan of action?
It cold.
Tell me what to do at every single node.
Uh,
it,
that,
that can't be the right definition because I cannot distinguish node.
So all it can be doing is telling me what to do at each information set.
Alright,
so it's specifies,
it specifies
what
player I
should do
should,
perhaps this is the wrong word as I say.
We'll do,
we'll do
at each
of eyes.
Information says,
all right,
so you go back,
uh,
about a week you'll see almost exactly the same definition of a strategy,
but the previous definition told I want to do at each node.
And this one just tells you what to do at each information center.
What I'm doing is tidying up the previous definition so we can apply it to the
more interesting games.
We're going to look out for an hour.
All right,
so now we have the definition of a strategy.
We can,
uh,
we can,
we can carry on the idea we've just seen here.
So what's the idea here?
Any game you give me in the form of a tree,
I can rewrite the game in the form of a matrix.
All right,
so let's see some other examples.
That idea,
that's a lot of new ideas today,
but some of them are just tidying up and kind of bookkeeping and some of them
are more interesting.
All right?
So let's start with a tree that's make a slightly more interesting tree than the
one we've seen before.
Actually,
that's too interesting.
That's,
let's go back a little bit slower.
So let's have player one have two choices
and play a to have three choices.
All right,
so here's a simple tree and let's put some payoffs in.
But let me just put some letters in for payoffs rather than putting in numbers.
All right.
So we'll call these actions upon down and we'll call this action left middle and
right and left middle and right.
And we'll call the payoffs a one a two B one B two c one c two d one d two e one
e two e and f one F two.
Alright,
so just to keep track of it and I want to show you how we take this tree and
turn it into a matrix.
All right,
so how do we,
how do we turn into a matrix where we look and say how many strategies is play a
one God and how many strategies player to got?
So play a one.
The here just has two strategies up or down and play.
A two has three strategies,
either left,
middle or right.
Again,
they can't choose separately at these two nodes.
So they really just have three choices left,
middle or right.
Leave a space here in your note book.
Leave a space to the right here and it's draw the Matrix for this tree down
here.
All right,
so here's my matrix.
Player two is choosing left middle or right,
and play on.
One is choosing up or down.
All right?
And the payoffs are go in as a in the obvious way.
So a one,
a two B,
one B,
two c one c two d one d two e one e two e and f one F two.
All right,
so everyone understands.
That was a simple exercise.
Just show we can to go from an extensive,
for a tree to the normal form,
the matrix.
All right?
However,
I guess that was easy,
right?
However,
there's an interesting thing here.
It isn't all of this that this is it.
If I just gave you the matrix,
it isn't obvious that this is the tree from which it came.
Let me draw another tree that I claim correspondence to that same matrix,
right?
Here's another tree.
So this other tree,
instead of having play a one Lou first,
it's going to have player to first player too,
but to have three choices and we'd better call them left middle and right,
and it better be the case.
That player one
is in one big information set and play a one only has two choices which will
call up and down.
Right?
Cause that's what this matrix is telling us.
It's telling us player to had three choices and plan what I pay two or three
choices and payer one at two choices.
So that's true in the,
in the,
in the Matrix I've drawn and it's been a little bit careful where the payoffs
are so left up.
That's easy.
That's going to be a one.
A two left down is going to be d one
d two Middle Aarp is going to be B one B two middle down it's going to be e one
e to uh,
write up is going to be c one c two and write down is going to be f one F two.
It had to be a little bit careful what I put the pay offs but I think that's
right.
I just did.
And notice that what I did here,
I started from this tree.
It was an easy operation to construct the matrix so easy that it was kind of
boring and it's not that hard to see things go the other way and construct this
other tree from,
from the Matrix.
This is also a tree in which player to history strategies and play out at one.
This is all player one Az,
two strategies.
All right,
so what?
What do we learn from this,
right?
What does this look at this more carefully.
This tree is a tree in which player one moved first and play a two didn't
observe player one's choice.
All right?
This is a tree in which plant to move first and play a one didn't observe two's
choice,
right?
What are we noticing here?
They're really the same game.
There's no difference between these two games,
all right?
They're really the same game.
It doesn't matter whether it's player one moving first and play a two who's
unable to observe once choice or whether it's player two's moving first and play
a woman who is unable to observe two's choice.
My all the matters is that neither play.
I could observe the other person's choice before they got to move.
They both correspond to exactly the same,
the same game.
All right,
so what's the message here?
The message is something we've talked about before in the class.
Trying to be a bit more formal about it.
The message is that what matters,
what matters
is information.
Well mine is,
is information,
not time,
not time.
Clearly time.
You couldn't,
anytime,
isn't it an irrelevant thing?
I couldn't know something that hasn't happened yet.
All right?
It's a time is going to have an effect on inflammation.
But ultimately what matters is information of what do we know and when did I
know it?
All right?
So the key idea there we're trying to capture with these information sets just
repeats is warranted the plan though.
And when did they know it right now a famous expression from the Watergate
trials.
Okay,
well let's look at a more interesting example and see if we can actually talk
about what's going to happen in these games.
Awesome.
Because by the end of the day,
I want to have enough machinery so we can actually start analyzing these games.
And predicting what's going to happen.
All right,
so as we go on we'll get more complicated.
So that's getting a little more complicated.
Now once again,
here's a game in which player one is going to have two choices and we'll call
those choices up or down and it's getting some of the [inaudible] and once
again,
play a two is going to move next and now this time just to keep things simple,
we'll have player to just have two choices left or right,
left or right,
but now to make things more interesting,
but let's have play a one move again.
If up rights happens,
then play a one gets to move again.
In which case play a one is going to choose up or down and I'll use a little
view and a little d to distinguish it from the worms are further to the left of
the tree.
All right.
She's a very simple tree.
Play a one moves first player to move second.
I forgot to put a two in here and then if up right as occurred,
then player one gets to move again.
Let's get some payoffs.
So let's have this be four two zero zero
one four
zero,
zero again
and to full.
Okay.
All right,
let's just carry on analyzing this game using exactly the methods we've been
talking about in the class today.
So far.
So the first thing I'm going to do is I want to turn this into a matrix or turn
this into a matrix.
And the first thing to do on the,
on that route is to try and figure out how many strategies does play a one have
and how many strategies that have play a two half.
All right?
And before we even do that,
let's try and figure out how many inflammation steps they have.
All right,
so I claimed the player to just has the one information set is that right place.
He just has the one information site,
but play a one has two information sets this information set at the beginning of
the game,
and then potentially the second information set down further down the tree.
All right.
As strategy ms tell you ever miss a strategy must tell the player what to do at
each of their information sets.
So the strategies for playout and one
strategies for player one,
I'll walk,
well,
one strategy is up and then up again.
Another strategy is up and then writes another strategy is down and then up on
the fourth strategy is down.
And then right,
I knew is something which we've seen already in this class before.
There's a little bit of a redundancy here.
These two down strategies,
these two down strategies,
uh,
forced the game into a,
forced the game into part of the tree where this node will not arise less
grandly if play a one chooses down,
she knows that she won't have to,
she won't have to make a choice of up or down later on.
J
thank you.
Sorry.
Thank you.
Thanks Jake.
All right,
let me start again.
Was actually the wrong rotation.
All right.
It's a player.
One's choices are up and then up,
up and then down,
down and then up and down and then down.
Thanks,
Jake.
Sorry.
All right.
And why are the four strategies,
it's a bit of a surprise perhaps because if player one chooses down,
then she knows she will never have to make a choice at her.
Second information says nevertheless.
Nevertheless,
we write down every week when we write down a strategy,
we have to write down an instruction for every single information sets.
So we include both of those strategies.
Strategies for play.
A two here are a little bit easier scratches for player to adjust left or right.
Okay.
All right.
With that in mind,
let's draw up the matrix.
Okay,
so play a one here has
okay.
Uh,
four strategies and they are up,
up,
down,
up and down,
down and play.
A two has two strategies and they all left or writes
hi everyone.
A case they're fun with.
Just basically transferring things across.
And then we have to convince where the payoffs across.
So up,
up,
followed by left is going to be for two,
uh,
up,
followed by rights is going to be zero up,
right,
resisting.
He was upright.
UPS operate up.
Is there a zero.
Okay.
Uh,
up left armpit down,
laughed as the same as up,
left down to it.
Skin fool too.
Up Down Rights is going to be up right down so it's going to be one
four
down.
Up left is the same as saying down left,
so it's going to be zero,
zero.
All right.
Down up rights is going to be too far
down.
Down left is,
once again,
I'm going to be a zero,
zero and down.
Down right is once again going to be two fold,
right?
Does everyone see how I got the payoffs?
I just use those strategies to tell me which way I'm going through the tree.
If I combine them,
it gives me an entire path and gets me to an end node.
Okay?
All right.
And you can see this redundancy we talked about,
we pointed out that these things,
I kind of the same thing and you can see in the matrix that the bottom four
squares of the matrix have repetition,
right?
This row is the same as that,
Alright.
Never happy with that.
Okay.
We have a matrix.
Let's analyze it by finding the Nash Equilibria.
In this game.
All right.
Sort of find the,
now she could have written this game.
We're going to find best responses.
All right,
so does it start by asking what is the best response to left so of player to
choose his left play on one's best response is either up for opt down if player,
uh,
to choose chooses rights than player one's best response is either down or up or
down.
Down.
All right,
we're okay so far.
All right.
If play a one chooses up up then play a two is going to choose left.
If play on one chooses up down than player two's best responses to choose
rights.
If play a one chooses down up than play a tos,
best responses to choose rights.
And if play a one chooses down down than plant two's best responses to choose.
Right?
All right,
so this is kind of slow and I just want to be,
be careful.
I'm being slow for a reason.
It's really what we're going to ground you to get harder.
I want to be able to care for.
You can see people looking at little sleepy around the room.
I know it's of lunchtime.
If you see your neighbor getting sleepy,
give them a good sharp elbow because I think this is,
this isn't a good time to fall asleep.
Sometimes I'm worried you're going to miss something and it's not going to get
harder.
They're gonna mess.
Thanks.
All right,
so what are the Nash Equilibrium in this game?
We knew how to do that.
The Nash equilibrium must be up,
up,
followed by left.
Try getting them all down,
up,
followed by right and down.
Down,
followed by,
right.
All right.
What?
These three Nash equilibrium.
Okay,
so that wasn't,
so that's a big deal.
I got three clever in this game and if I had simply given you this game in the
first half of the semester,
I hadn't shown you the tree.
You never seen this tree?
Yeah.
Just gave you this game and instead find the Nash Equilibrium.
This game.
That'd be a question on the mid term.
We'd have stopped here.
All right.
We just said,
okay,
I found these Nash Equilibria.
Maybe you'd gone on to found mixed ones.
I don't know.
But essentially where we'd be down at this point,
right?
Say again,
if we'd started as we would have done before the mid term with me giving you a
payoff matrix and asking you to find the national equilibria and then at this
point we'd be done.
We'd have found the three now she could have released the three pure strategy
now sheik,
whatever the problem is,
if we go back to the tree,
to the dynamic game,
the game that has some action going on in meds and actually look at this game,
it's not clear that all of these Nash Equilibria are really equally plausible.
All right.
Can anyone see what might be bit implausible about some of these Nash
Equilibrium?
What's,
what's implausible about them?
Can you take us on this?
Wow,
let's look at this.
This game again or this game's a little bit complicated.
It's not clear what one should do here perhaps,
and perhaps it's not clear what player to should do here because after all play
to a,
it doesn't know where he is and he doesn't know where the player one.
If pay one gets to move again is going to choose apoe down box.
What's the bus?
Yeah,
we get a mic on,
on uh,
on Patrick.
Yeah.
So if you look at it backwards,
you can cross out player one second choice.
He's always going to choose down.
So that's one floor at that note.
Good.
Then you know,
player two is always going to choose the right because this payoff is always for
good player wines.
Not going to have any player.
One knows which to choose.
Then he's going to choose down.
Good.
So there's this,
this,
this works.
What Patrick just said.
That's very good.
So if we just don't,
we just analyze this data and the way we've been taught to analyze trees.
Essentially using backward induction.
We first all observe the,
that the player one gets to move again here.
She'll know where she is and she'll move.
She's choosing between one and zero.
She's going to choose down.
Is that right?
But knowing this player too,
even though player to doesn't know where he is player to actually has a pretty
easy choice to make.
He knows that if he chooses a left he either gets two oh zero but if he chews
his rights he gets four right?
Four is bigger than two.
Four is bigger than zero so play it too is actually going to choose.
Right and given that given the player two is going to choose rights play,
a warm is essentially choosing between one if if she chooses up,
which would be followed by writing down and two which was what happened if she
chooses down followed by.
Right.
So this game we can essentially analyzed through backward induction.
I don't quite back conduction cause we had to add in this little piece about two
not knowing where she was but it turned out no matter where she was,
she had a dominant strategy.
Has she had a better strategy one,
she figures out that player one is going to shoes down.
Is that right?
If we go back and look at these Nash Equilibria,
the prediction that we just got,
which is what down for playout one,
right?
For player too.
And then down again for player one.
Alright,
that strategy is this one.
All right?
So one of these Nash Equilibria corresponds to our sensible analysis of this
tree,
but the other two do not.
These two national equilibria
inconsistent
with backward induction,
but the inconsistent with backward induction,
right?
That perfectly good.
Now she got a,
we've given you this matrix at the mid term,
you'd have thought that just fine,
but it turns out both of these Nash Equilibria involve play a one choosing a
strategy up that we know the player one is not going to do if reached.
And one of these Nash Equilibria involves player to choosing a strategy,
uh,
left.
Then in fact she's only choosing because play out because she thinks player too
as probably one is going to choose.
Oh,
which in fact we've just argued Pli one is not going to do all.
All right?
The people at the back there.
There's a little bit too much volume bouncing off the wall that so just keep it,
keep it down in the balcony.
Thank you.
All right.
All right,
so these two,
these two met Nash Equilibria that perfectly good.
Now she could have heard of the game,
but they don't make any sense,
right?
They're completely inconsistent with the way we've learned to talk about gangs.
All right,
now we've seen this before.
We sort on the entry game.
This is a much more complicated,
much more interesting example,
but we saw in the entry game when there was one entrance entering into a market
that didn't,
that game,
there were actually two national equilibria and one of them we argued was
incredible.
Here it's a bit more complicated,
but nevertheless,
these two equilibria seemed like bogus equilibria,
whatever will equilibrate we wouldn't really believe it.
And the reason we don't believe in them is that they don't correspond to
backward induction and our common sense intuitions about backward induction.
All right,
so we need some new notion.
The aim of the class,
there's been lot.
We want to be able to model games that have both sequential moves and a
simultaneous moves and we wanted to be able to look at the games and use our
techniques from both parts of the class.
We want to be able to use the idea of Nash equilibrium from the first half of
the class and we wanted to be able to use the idea of backward induction from
the second half of the cost.
But what we're learning here is that Nash Equilibrium,
if we just take the notion of Nash equilibrium it and plunk it down on the
sequential move game,
ms,
it will produce equilibria that don't make any sense.
So we need a more refined notion of equilibrium,
a better notion of equilibrium than just nash equilibrium to deal with these
settings where we have both simultaneity and sequential news,
we have both,
uh,
some perfect information and some imperfect information.
All right?
That was one example.
Let me give you a second example.
If that example wasn't yet convinced that,
all right,
let me leave that example up.
So far
we've seen the nash equilibrium gets us into trouble in these games and we've
seen it got us into trouble because it basically conflicted with our backward
induction intuitions.
Now I'm going to show you a different game and we're going to see what the game,
the Nash Equilibrium is going to get us into trouble.
All right,
this is going to be a three player game.
We'll get more complicated as we go along.
So another example,
this time with three plans,
there's an example of get harder.
I needed to be more alert to see if you can follow them.
All right,
so this a more complicated tree.
Here's a tree in which play on one moves first and chooses between a or B.
And if play at one chooses a,
the game is over,
she gets one and the other two players get nothing.
If she chooses B,
then players two and three
get to play a little game man here.
Which two moves first and this little sub game and three moves second and the
payoffs in this sub game are as follows.
Again,
using player ones pay off first.
So there's zero one one zero zero two,
okay.
Zero zero minus one and two one zero.
All right.
So this is quite a complicated game.
It's got three players for a start.
So it's gonna be a bit hard to draw to draw it up in a matrix.
Uh,
but nevertheless,
let me try and do that.
So I claim that we can model this game as follows.
Uh,
it's a game in which play a one is choosing which Matrix score has matrix a
and matrix B
play.
One is choosing the Matrix,
play a two is choosing,
it's called them up and down.
Play a two is choosing,
okay,
up or down and play.
A three is choosing left or right.
All right.
And they're just in this game,
uh,
play,
play as two and three actually can observe the choice of arb to start with.
All right,
so let's try and put in the payoffs and the correct places.
It's not always easy to do,
but it's try.
So a is easy.
If play one chooses a,
then the payoff from this matrix are somewhat trivial because of player warm.
She says,
Hey,
whatever.
Anyone else does the pay off is one zero zero
all right,
somewhat,
somewhat uninteresting matrix over that.
But if plaid one chooses B,
then life gets more interesting.
Then uh,
play it.
If player to chooses out on player three chooses left,
we ended up here.
So that's zero one one if player one player two chooses to,
and this is three
two and this is a three if play a two chooses AARP on player three shoes,
his rights then worked zero zero two all right,
so this is zero zero two going in here.
If player two shoes is down and play a three chooses left,
then we're at zero zero minus one.
Okay with that and if player to chooses down and play it three bruises down,
then we're down here,
which is two one zero
all right.
Okay,
so here's a little game player.
One is choosing the Matrix,
play it.
Two is choosing the row in the matrix or be at AAA on the left hand side and
play a three is choosing the column in the Matrix.
Again,
albeit trivially on the lefthand side,
we don't already care about about this picture very much.
All right.
Okay,
so now watch now what?
Well,
once again,
we could look for Nash equilibrium in this game.
It turns out there are lots of Nash equilibrium in this game.
All right,
let me just show you one Nashik,
whatever him and then we'll talk about it.
All right,
so I claim I claim that there are lots of national put our brand
and one of them,
one of them
is the Nash Equilibrium.
A
Oh,
okay.
Left a left.
So that's see what that is.
And the tree,
first of all,
so player one shows a player to just up and left,
but it followed a,
so we ended up here.
We ended up at one zero zero
all right,
Gotcha.
Hey,
op left is this box in the tree?
All right,
let's just check that.
That actually is a nash equilibrium.
All right?
So we all know how to do this from the first half of the class to check.
And that's a Nash equilibrium.
We better check that no individual player can do better by deviating.
So let's start with playing a one.
If play a one deviates holding player two and three fixed than play a one,
we'll be switching the matrix from matrix a to Matrix B.
Is that correct?
Alright so we'll move from this box in the lefthand matrix to the equivalent box
in the right hand matrix,
right?
And play a ones pay off.
We'll go from one to zero,
one to zero.
So play a one doesn't want to d gate everyone happy with that one.
Doesn't want to deviate here.
How about player to player to deviates holding players one in three fixed then
play a one is going to switch rose and this matrix.
So we'll move from this box to this.
Right from this box to this box.
Play a two was making zero before she's still making zero.
So she just has no incentive to deviate and the same argument applies for player
three cause she will bring to choosing the column holding the row in the matrix
fixed.
So once again she gets zero in either case.
All right,
you ever unhappy with that?
So that actually is and how she could have rum.
And again,
if this had been the midterm,
I could have set this up.
I could have given you these matrices,
uh,
or the story behind them and you'd have found that you could,
I could have asked you whether this was a nash equilibrium and the answer would
have been yes.
But I claim that once again,
this is just not a believable nash equilibrium.
It isn't actually whatever Emma Foreign International,
the room,
but it's not a plausible prediction for how this game is going to be a place.
Why is it not a plausible prediction for how this game is going to be played?
I want to see stare at the tree of it,
right?
So in in the information here and the pre mid term information,
it's fine.
But knowing about the actual structure of this game,
I claim this makes no sense at all.
Why does it make no sense?
Well,
notice that if play or one word to switch her action from the prescribed action,
a call to action be then we'd be here.
All right.
And notice that the tree from here on in looks like a little game.
That right the tree from here on looks like a little game,
right?
So this thing here is put in green.
This thing here is a little game within the game.
It's a sub game.
All right?
And there's some game really only involved two players,
the two players that it involves.
I'll play us too and play a three player.
One's done play ones put us into this game.
But now in this little son game,
it's a little sub game involving just player too and player three.
So we can analyze this little sub game.
If we analyze it,
it'll some game.
What will it give us?
What will we find?
All right,
so let's look at this sub game.
So look at the green,
the green,
some game game that would have happened.
Hand player one,
chosen B.
This is a sock game involving,
just play as two and three.
So one,
let us forget player one.
All right,
we know what I mean.
Play.
One is part of the game is getting payoffs,
but play a one has made their move.
They're not really involved anymore.
So let's just look at this game as a game involving players two and three.
And let's look at the Matrix for players two and three.
So this is,
this actually corresponds to the matrix above.
It's a,
it's a matrix in which player two is choosing up and down.
Here it is up and down and simultaneously play at three is choosing left or
right.
Here it is.
Laughter Rights at this inflammation.
Sas and the payoffs are one one
zero two
okay.
Zero minus one
[inaudible].
Alright.
All right,
so this is a claim,
a representation of this little green game.
I should put this in green as well.
All right,
this thing corresponds to that thing.
I'm okay with that.
Alright,
so if player one had chosen to chew a chosen B rather than a,
then we'd be involved in a little game,
a game within the game or sub game involving just play as two or three and we
can analyze that game.
That's a straight forward gay man.
Here it is.
And what would we do with that game?
We'd look for the Nash Equilibrium in that game.
So let's look for the Nash Equilibrium in this game.
So what do we notice about this game?
So if player three chooses left,
then play out to would rather choose up.
If plan a three chooses a rights,
then player two should choose down.
If play a two chooses op than play a three would rather choose rights because
two is bigger than one.
And if play a two or to choose down,
then play a three wood shoes,
right?
Again,
because Xero is bigger than minus one.
Okay?
So in fact in this little sub game and this little sub game actually play a
three has a dominant strategy,
right?
If it turned out that we got involved in this little sub game play,
a three has a dominant strategy,
which is to play writes.
And moreover this some game has just one nash equilibrium.
If I'd given you this sub game on its own,
it's clear that the Nash Equilibrium of this sub game,
this game within the game is
down rice.
It's down,
right?
So what's that telling us?
It's telling us if play a two and three ever get called upon to play in this
game.
I only happens when a prior one chooses bead.
If play a two and three ever get called upon to play on this game.
We know from when we were young or at least from before the midterm,
we know that they're going to play Nash equilibrium in that sub game and the
Nash Equilibrium in the sub game,
he's going to have play at three choosing reits and play it to choosing down.
Alright,
but the equilibrium,
we talked about this equilibrium we owe all good before about a UL was doesn't
the equipment told them before.
A UL doesn't involve player to choosing down in facts.
She shows up and it doesn't involve player three choosing rights.
In fact,
she
should.
I just left.
All right,
so let's set up
this.
We found an equilibrium of this game cause he could have run this game was a u l
but I claimed this is not a plausible equilibrium.
It's not a plausible equilibrium because it predicts that if we actually would
have played the game within the game,
we wouldn't in play equilibrium.
Let me say it again.
In the whole game and the whole game,
a op left isn't equilibrium,
but I claim it's a silly equilibrium because he didn't vols the prediction that
if in fact we ever got into the game within the game,
we would no longer play equilibrium.
And that doesn't seem right.
If we're going to believe in equilibrium,
we should be consistent and believe in equilibrium.
All right,
so this brings us to a new idea,
right?
And the new idea is going to have two parts to it.
The first part is kind of on the border.
Ready?
It's something we try to informally,
it's the notion of a sub game.
It's the motion of a sub game,
right?
What's a sum game?
It's a game within a game.
All right?
I've been using that informally,
but we need to start thinking about more formally what it means.
All right,
so I talked to,
I didn't form an asset that green objects is the game that would be played.
We're player one to choose B and we told her the other sub games in this class
we talked about the sum game that would happen in the entry game if one of
those,
one of those uh,
rival became rival pizza companies moved in,
in uh,
the Miami market or something.
There was a game within a game and we took out the Tour de France.
We talked about the being game within a game that is about when you break away.
But I want to be formal about this notion of a game within a game and introduce
some of the main culture.
So the formal definition is this definition of a sound game.
He sub game
is a part of a game.
Okay.
In full bleed,
looks like a game
within the tree
and it has three properties.
It satisfies the following three properties.
So since it looks like a game itself,
the sub game must start from a particular point.
So it starts the sub game,
ms start,
it starts from a single mode.
And let's just look at the example and the example we just looked at.
The sub game started from this mode here.
Second,
second
it comprises can praises,
oh,
successes,
successes to that node.
Okay,
so now our example,
here's all sub games are green sock game.
Here's the note.
It starts from here.
All the nodes that are successes of that node.
These are the children and these are the grandchildren.
All right?
You have this grandparent node,
you have to have all of his children had all of his grandchild.
All right?
So it comprises all the successes of that load.
And finally,
and this is important,
it does not.
It does not break up,
does not break up any information sets.
It does not break up any information sets.
So some game informally it's just a little game within the game,
but slightly more formally.
I can't put one node that's part of an information site into this sub game and
it's not going to put all the nodes that are part of that information set into
the subject.
All right,
let's have a look at some examples.
We've got one example out there.
The entry game look something like this,
right?
The entry game.
It's something like this.
So what are the sub games here?
So no secrets here.
This is a sub game,
right?
There's actually another sub gang.
Want to see what the other sub game is?
The whole game is a sub game.
Alright?
The whole game is itself a stop gap.
Somewhat trickily.
All right,
so this is this,
this particular game,
just the [inaudible],
which is a schematic of the entry game.
It has actually two sub games,
but only one proper sub game.
Here's a more complicated example.
Oh,
he's actually gonna be quite a complicated example just to make life
interesting.
So one is going to move,
then two is going to move,
okay?
And then one is going to move again.
This is all one big information set to play a one
and
one is going to move like this.
So again,
without pay offs,
this is a little tree.
And the key point here is this is an inflammation.
So
all right,
let's look at stare at this tree a second and figure out what are and and not
sub games.
So first of all,
what does this,
this was a sub game and this was a sub game.
What about this thing here?
Is that a sub game?
It's not as what,
what,
what role does it break?
It's,
it's breaking up an inflammation set,
right?
It's breaking up an information set.
So that's no good because of rule three.
What about this thing?
Yeah,
that doesn't break up and inflammation.
So that I've got the hold inflammation set in that.
Is that any good?
No,
that's no good because it doesn't start from a singles and node.
That's no good.
It violates one.
And uh,
if we do this,
we look at this piece,
that piece there,
that's also new.
Good.
Why is that?
No good?
Again,
it breaks up an information set.
All right,
so this is no good again because of rule three.
All right.
So you can,
you can practice at home drawing trees and trying to identify what are I don't
what to not sub gates.
All right.
So with us with a definition of a stub game now formal,
right?
It's basically just formalizing something we've talked about before,
which is the idea of a game within the game.
I want to introduce our new,
what's going to be our new solution concepts and this is going to be the
solution concept.
We're going to use essentially a almost until the final
definition,
so just remember what our task is.
Our task is to come up with a solution concepts that picks up the idea from the
first half of the semester,
namely Nash Equilibrium,
but does so in a way that respects what we've learned in the second half of the
semester.
Namely that games have sequential elements and people move by backward
induction.
So in particular what we want to rule out are those Nash Equilibria that
instructs players down the tree to play in some games according to strategies
that are not Nash Equilibria is that again,
we want to rule out those national whatever,
then instruct people way down the tree to play according to something which is
not an athlete.
Whatever.
We want our new notion to say wherever you find yourself in a tree,
play Nashik,
whatever.
I'm about to exactly what the definition is going to say.
So a Nash Equilibrium,
n e s one star,
two star all the way up to s m star is a sub gay men.
Perfect subgame perfect equilibrium
slub game,
perfect equilibrium is that's an s p e.
It's a subgame perfect equilibrium.
If
eight induces
a nash equilibrium in every sub game,
oh of the game.
So getting poverty group equally or remit,
it has to itself be an ashy color rim of course,
but it also has to instruct players to play a nash equilibrium in every stop
game.
Let's take that immediately back to our examples.
In this example and this example we know,
let's bring it down and this example,
we know that this is a sub game.
We know that in this sub game there is only one nash equilibrium and that Nash
equilibrium,
it involves player to choosing down and player three choosing rights,
all rights.
So we know,
we know that plant two is going to choose down according to that equilibrium and
player three is going to choose right according to that equilibrium.
So we now have a look for an equilibrium of the whole game.
Let's go back to play a one's choice.
Play on warm.
If they choose a,
we'll get one.
If they chose B,
then they know that this nash equilibrium will we played.
So I'll get to,
they prefer two to one.
So the subgame perfect equilibrium here is play a one chooses B,
play it to chooses down and player three shoes is right.
This is an equilibrium of the game and it induces.
Here it is.
It induces
an equilibrium and this type game.
All right,
so with that example,
the subgame perfect.
Your equilibrium is found by first of looking in the sub game,
find the equilibrium in the sub game and then go back and look at the
equilibrium of the whole game.
He could've move.
We ended up with,
it is a nash equilibrium in the whole game,
but more importantly it induces and Nash equilibrium in the sub game.
Let's just go back to our other examples.
Then I'll stop.
So our other example was here.
Okay.
He was our other example.
We claim,
hang on everybody.
We claimed the good equilibrium here.
The one we believed in,
it was down down rights.
All right,
where are the sub games and this game?
What are the sub games and this tree?
Anybody?
So I claim there's only one real sub game here and that's this piece,
right?
This is a sub game.
All right?
Watch the Nash equilibrium of this somewhat trivial sub game.
Okay?
I'm actually gonna move this somewhat trivial sum game is that player one miss
choose down.
So for a national equilibrium,
it to be a subgame perfect equilibrium.
Here are our three Nash Equilibria.
One,
two,
three.
For this nash equilibrium to be a subgame perfect equal aroma,
it's got to instruct,
play a one to choose down in the trivial sub gate.
And here it is.
This is our subgame perfect equilibrium in this game.
Now I know today was a lot of formal stuff,
a lot of new ideas.
We come back on Monday,
well first of all,
give you a game that refreshes these ideas and then we'll go straight to
applications to trust me,
there will be applications.
It will be useful.
See you on Monday.
There's a homework to come in and there's another one on the web or going out.